hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast more than data a new
generation of image sensors and signal
processing presented by ratchet Mahendra
product manager for life science
research cameras photometrics we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by fellow metrics a company
that designs and manufactures
high-performance cameras for life
science research those of you who may
not be aware photometrics is the
original architect of the world's first
scientific grade microscopy tem ccd
camera today the company continues to
lead the industry with its
state-of-the-art scientific imaging
instrumentation which leverages a wide
range of sensor technology every day
researchers from around the globe rely
on these cutting-edge solutions to
accomplish their most demanding imaging
requirements to learn more about
photometrics and its products you can
visit their website at WWF Adam XCOM I
am Julie O'Rourke love lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the cee button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit and
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you get to an
a button to let us know that you're
having a problem thank you now I'd like
to introduce ratchet mahindra as the
product manager for life science
research cameras and photometrics
ratchet has been intimately involved
with the EMC CD revolution that was
mental in the development of new methods
in single molecule detection and
super-resolution microscopy his
experience in managing the design
intricacies of CCD as seen loss and emt
CD cameras has given him a unique
perspective on emerging light detection
technologies and their expected impact
on life science microscopy please join
me in welcoming ratchet Mahendra I will
now turn the presentation over to him hi
everyone welcome to this webinar thank
you for joining us we see that we've got
quite a few people on here people from
industry some competitors users good
spread of what we'd like to see but this
webinar it's about the next generation
of image sensors and signal processing
and how that can be applied to life
sciences and microscopy and so the types
of image sensors that we typically place
into our cameras especially when
considering that we're designing for
very low light applications there have
been see CDs the charge coupled device
they've been around since I'd saved the
the mid-1970s and there they've been the
workhorse for digital imaging for the
last 20 years or so and in the
situations where see CDs just haven't
been sensitive enough for having been
fast enough there was a variation
developed right around 2000 2001 I'd say
called the EMC CD the electron
multiplying CCD what this did was it
took signal that you'd measured
multiplied it up above the noise gave
you way more sensitivity that that you
could work with and the the last
technology that gets used r CMOS sensors
these are basically integrated circuits
that are sensitive to light that offer a
pretty decent advantage compared to some
of the other technologies and to sort of
go through how these technologies have
been used in the past through 2010 2010
see CDs were the preferred imaging
technology
this is definitely reflected by most of
the cameras that were available at the
time I think photometrics itself at the
time had think five or six different
versions of ccd cameras and the reason
for this was simply they gave you good
resolution they gave you good
sensitivity they gave you a good frame
rate the the sort of trade off that you
typically experienced unfortunately was
that you could pick two of those three
and typically the it came down to
resolution and sensitivity because
though that's what see CDs were very
good at when it came to frame rate you
sort of came up against a wall the
faster you went you would either have to
trade off in the number of pixels or
your resolution or the amount of noise
you ended up in your images the faster
you went the the noisier your images
were but in general they provided enough
imaging versatility for a large variety
of applications ranging from you know
fix cell fluorescence out to you know
some of the different life cell
lifestyle applications that you could
expect that when ccds weren't enough as
I've mentioned the EMC CD became the the
other option and that's mostly because
they were way more sensitive and they
provided a much higher frame rate there
were nine times more sensitive the
near-perfect conversion of photons you
know sensitivity for imaging
single-molecule single-molecule
fluorescence and by having higher frame
rates so I think ccds at the time or
somewhere around 11 to 12 frames per
second EMCC be cameras offered frame
rates that were of three to six times
faster at the time eam cameras right
about 30 frames a second for the last
few years they've been up to about 60 or
70 frames a second and so EMC CD cameras
were able to provide that that level of
performance that ccds weren't able to
quite get you and so between both of
these technologies you were able to
cover the the gamut of your requirements
for the different applications
and by being able to provide this level
of sensitivity and frame rate and speed
it enabled the development of new
techniques new applications the Nobel
Prize was just awarded out for
super-resolution microscopy and that was
primarily developed and accomplished
using am ccd cameras now no technology
is perfect and with EMC CD cameras the
trade-off for that higher level of
sensitivity that frame rate was that you
ended up with a bit more noise in your
images the electron multiplication
process the the process that you use to
reduce the effects of the read noise
that that allows you to image those
those very dim sample the
single-molecule fluorescence it's a
stochastic multiplication process and so
it adds an additional statistical
variance in in how much or how much
noises on your image which affects the
it makes your fluorescent measurements
less precise while you're able to see
things the the noise and your images are
larger less precision in your in your
data and this this affected your signal
to noise ratio and typically when it
came down to see cds or emc cities as
the decision-making factor it always
went down it came down to applications
and people typically had to choose
between those two till about 2010 when s
CMOS technology arrives and for the most
part replaces CCD technology as I
mentioned earlier see CDs made you
typically pick between speed resolution
and sensitivity you got two of the three
as CMOS made it simple you got
everything it was three times larger ten
times faster five times less noise and
what it allows you to do is really
bridge the gap between where see cds and
emc CD cameras and sensors
were in terms of performance and so if
we take a comparison look God this is a
standardized fluorescents light that can
be used for intensity calibration what
we have on the top is a ccd camera the
cool snap easy at a relatively low light
level it's about a 10 millisecond
acquisition and underneath that we have
an S CMOS camera that happens to be the
photometrics Prime and as you can
clearly tell that at these lower light
levels the the lower read noise the
higher sensitivity clearly makes a
difference and you're you're able to get
better signal-to-noise ratios get better
precision in your measurements you're
able to get better call the be data and
as a proof that it brought you closer to
our EMC CDs were if you compare that
same as CMOS image at the bottom to an
emc City at the top you'll see it's
actually really close yes the signal
levels are higher on the e/m camera and
they always will be emc CD cameras will
always be more sensitive than be a CMOS
bed it's it's quite comparable and so
when it comes to applications there
there are quite a few criteria that you
need to you need to consider typically
depending on your objective the
magnification the na the pixel size of
fear sensor there there are some some
trade-offs and experimental parameters
that you have to take into consideration
EMC CD cameras have quite large pixels
this is one of the one of the reasons
why they're so sensitive these large
pixels allow you to measure much more
light per pixel and so what you trade
off in spatial information you gain and
being able to measure much lower levels
of signal but a larger pixel typically
requires a higher level of magnification
to be able to achieve
what is a proper sampling rate or what's
called the the Nyquist frequency for
sampling wow this basically just means
you really want to have two pixels per
resolution self so you can you know
maximize your your spatial information
without under sampling so you know when
a feature begins and ends effectively
but with this larger pixel that requires
the higher magnification they're there
they're straight offs higher
magnification means that your overall
field of view the the area that you're
able to image is smaller and because of
the higher magnification the the amount
of flight you have the photon flux is
now spread over a wider area and so you
effectively get less light per pixel and
so while trying to balance these
parameters it can you know it can become
quite challenging and especially when
you have those those loads large pixels
that you have to balance Sun so
primarily for that reason because SD mas
performance is so close to her the EMC
CD is many users many researchers have
tried to push a CMOS technology to where
emc CD cameras to current we are one of
the one of the parameters are one of if
if you look at this trust triangle here
what this basically emphasizes is that s
CMOS cameras gave you you know speed in
the resolution and they gave you decent
sensitivity but when when you're imaging
at higher magnifications or very dim
samples that's the sensitivity becomes
absolutely critical the first challenge
in microscopy is can I see it and then
the second consideration is how well can
I see it and s CMOS cameras uh they
didn't while close to e m cameras they
didn't always do as well and so if you
look at a comparison here what we have
is the s CMOS camera the photometrics
prime at a hundred x magnification
definitely over sampling spatially here
compared to the emc see
at a hundred and fifty expectation now
the the reason for that is again to
adequately sample an e/m camera with the
16 microns by 16 micron pixel requires a
much higher level of magnification to
appropriately spatially sample and so
when you get that comparison yes you've
traded off in field of view and the the
amount of light per pixel but just
having that level of sensitivity and
effectively appropriate pixel size with
the difference in magnification the e/m
CCD camera still gives you a better
signal to noise performance or better
signal to background as you can see
there's there's better contrast and the
reason for this really is the e/m game
the the ability for the e/m ccd sensor
to maximize the amount of signal you're
able to detect by amplifying the light
above the noise as that little diagram
shows what what AM game does is a
multiplier signal up above the level of
noise they're making it detectable
typically we you'll hear us say you know
as camera people will be like yeah
you're reducing the noise to less than
an electron it's a proportional
reduction but how the camera or the
sensor itself physically works is by
amplifying the signal well above the
noise and so as there's no way to do
this with an S CMOS sensor there's no
there there are no EMC mosques cameras
around at this time and so one way to
maximize what your signal to noise ratio
is or the image quality that you can
achieve with an S CMOS camera is
actually through image processing while
you're not necessarily able to increase
your overall level of signal per per
frame like you can with an EMC CD what
you can do is leverage the information
that's available in the image itself to
try and minimize the noise that might be
that might be present
and by doing that what you you're
effectively doing is maximizing what
your signal to noise ratio would be the
ability to discern what as actual signal
and reducing the noise while not in the
same way as am ccd cameras but to
achieve similar results and so it's
possible to do this active noise
reduction if you think about how our
eyes behave when we're running the focus
loop with the camera and we're looking
at a feature there are times where our
eyes are there great app removing the
noise from the image and this is quite
actually easily seen when you're looking
at a self you draw a line profile across
some of the features some of the
filaments within and you're able to see
the structures but not necessarily
measure them that's because our eyes are
able to filter out effectively that high
frequency noise and so by leveraging the
ability of our eyes to detect these
patterns and structures in the image
where we can leverage that and put that
you know on the camera itself to get
this noise reduction in in real time
effectively and achieve levels of
denoising or increase in signal to noise
ratio by factors of 3 to 5 X and that's
a that's a pretty significant increase
in terms of image quality now there's
always concerns that come up especially
when image processing becomes a part of
the conversation people are always
concerned what are you doing to my data
are you introducing any artifacts is
that it they don't want it to
necessarily be a black box image data
goes in something comes out that's
better and so if you have a quantitative
algorithm that maintains the finer
features and is published actually so it
that's definitely not a black box this
this publication that literally says
denoising fluorescence microscopy image
sequences an algorithm that's designed
specifically for microscopy to give you
this increase in signal to noise ratio
demonstrates a increased clarity and
better data image processing algorithm
and so in these images that you see here
on the Left we have a hundred
millisecond exposure that we took with
one of our cameras and which you can
even see the structures the the
filaments in the behind that line
profile but when you look at the data
coming off that line profile itself you
can see maybe some of the peaks and
valleys but you sort of run into a
little bit of noise effect try to use
this arrow function let's see so you can
see that peak you can see that Valley he
can maybe see this one but in let's see
I can pilot stuff in this area you sort
of losing out and so when you turn on
the denoising feature what you get is
clarity in that same region it's not
about amplifying the signal it's about
reducing the noise that's present in the
image and what that allows you to do is
not change the intensities it's not
about changing the data there it's about
removing the uncertainty it's about
maximizing that precision and what that
allows you to do is really no really
measure the difference it's not just not
just visually seeing it but being able
to measure what what those peaks and
valleys are just as I didn't mention
this but those are the same exposures
one with the feature off one would the
feature on and you can clearly see that
you're getting better signal-to-noise
now signal-to-noise can is measured
differently by everyone some people do
signal to background some people signal
to send it how does this affect people
experimentally that that's what people
always really want to know you know this
is all nice but how will this affect my
my imaging my experiments what this
denoising functionality allows you to do
is effectively get the quality of data
as if you have eight to ten times more
light and so well what you'll see in
these graphs here the the first graph is
a again i think it's a it's a hundred
millisecond exposure you see the line
profile on the cell to the left now the
pink values are decently visible if we
take eight times more light and eight
times longer exposure time so if we go
from 100 milliseconds to 800
milliseconds as you would expect the
quality if that data gets better you
know the peaks and valleys are more
well-defined there's less variation
along that curve you're getting better
quality data out of it but there's
trade-offs to eight hundred millisecond
means eight times more light more
phototoxicity more photo bleaching your
cells are less happy and the challenge
is typically not be imaging that keeping
yourselves alive long enough to be able
to get the answers or the information
you need so anytime you're able to
reduce that you know keep yourselves
happy for longer the better your results
will be and so what the denoising
algorithm allows you to do is get the
quality of data that's equivalent to
eight to ten times more light so if you
look at that last graph along the bottom
that's the same hundred millisecond
exposure with the denoising
functionality and you get arguably a
better line profile through the through
the sample then eight times more light
and so by being able to really reduce
that light and you know extend exposures
or extended experiments become much more
possible now how does this perform on n
on an S CMOS camera you would get some
performance that looks like that on the
left there is the original s CMOS
acquisition and on the right is the the
D noise acquisition you can see that the
the noise in the background the
variations they are clearly removed some
of those features are
are now visible within the within that
neuron there and so how does this
compare to e.m cameras right but that's
one of the reasons why this denoising
algorithm becomes important because s
CMOS cameras are continuously being
pushed towards the level of performance
or the applications where EMCC d cameras
are used and so if we do that comparison
on the left is the EMC GD camera on the
right is the same denoise image staff
from VF CMOS camera you can see that
they become much more comparable you're
able to reduce the noise in the S CMOS
image to really bring out the the the
intensities that are actually present
and they're actually quite comparable
especially tui em ccd cameras now
processing will will always be an option
but the real question is why can't a
CMOS physically itself be as sensitive
as EMCC cameras or why remc she needs
more sensitive now one of the the key
features or the key I guess differences
between the two types of technologies is
how the pixels collect light the s CMOS
sensor uses micro lenses on top of the
pixel to direct light to the light
sensitive area effectively its front
illuminated and so what this means is
that in front of the light sensitive
area are all the wires that allow you to
do the readout to transfer the image
data to the computer the reason for the
microlenses is to get the light past
past those wires to get the light to
that light sensitive area and so it's
based off of this that the effective QE
or quantum efficiency of CMOS devices is
around you know seventy to eighty
percent the way that Sony
in the past Sony probably has the most
advanced Mac realistic technology out
there and they were able to achieve
about 75% with their with their ccds a
CMOS devices today claim about 80% it's
about the high end there somewhere
between 75 and eighty percent is the
best variable to get the way that emc
CDs do it is they just move the micro
lenses and the wires out of the way they
get rid of the micro lenses and they
effectively flip the the sensor upside
down or the the light-sensitive very
upside down it's called backside
illumination but by in fact they thin
the sensor down so now the light
sensitive area sits just above the wires
and so there's no objects in the way
there's no wiring there's no lens
trickery to get your light to the light
sensitive area and this way you're able
to truly maximize what your overall
sensitivity can be that's how emc TV
cameras can get to that ninety
ninety-five percent level of sensitivity
and so I guess the natural question from
that comes to be well why haven't we
done this on CMOS devices and it's not a
unique questions the question that's
been tried and attempted over the years
it has to be it's as I said not unique
that it's difficult but it's it's now
available there is a backside
illuminated CMOS sensor available and
what it demonstrates is that yes it is
possible to get to a near-perfect 95%
quantum efficiency across the visible
range there and so when you compare it
to the eighty-two percent sensitivity
you see that it's better all the way
across and it can be easy to to simulate
these curves but if you do a comparison
between the two technologies if you look
at a eighty-two percent s CMOS camera
compared to a back
illuminated CMOS what we have here is
the 30 millisecond exposure and I think
we're looking at some mouse hippocampal
neurons they're expressing emre beam
what we're looking at is the development
of these dendritic spines and these
neurons are actually extremely
photobleaching phototoxicity sensitive
when one of them dies or bleaches they
all died in Bleach and so it becomes
quite challenging especially when you
need to use much lower levels of light
to be able to detect these and so here
we see a 30 millisecond exposure
comparing a front illuminated eighty
percent scientific CMOS to a ninety-five
percent back-illuminated CMOS you can
clearly tell that the signal levels the
background is much much better on the
the back illuminated CMOS now if you go
to higher levels of flight you know if
that's always an option or something
that you're able to do with your samples
and the performance does get a little
bit closer but the 94 the the
ninety-five percent camera still because
if its sensitivity will give you better
signal-to-noise overall and we just
happen to do a side-by-side comparison
between the two cameras at different
exposure times and so it comes out that
the back illuminated camera with its
quantum efficiency and slightly larger
pixels is actually about three times
more sensitive than than current CMOS
technology the other part of this that
we've we've noticed with with this
different technology by being able to
run the center through a different
process to be able to get the back
thinning and the the pixel structure and
the the sensor working the noise
performance has actually improved quite
a bit too if we take those same image
stacks I believe these are the 30
millisecond acquisitions and you average
them together you're able to see this
pattern noise in the background of the
of the front illuminated CMOS sensor
the way the sensors are structured all
CMOS cameras have these columns that
allow you to digitize it allows you to
read out your data in parallel and
that's how you're able to get some of
these higher frame rates at very low
noise but all of these columns have some
variability and gain and offset and
other sort of peculiar features that
need to be corrected and by all camera
manufacturers and one of the the
consistent complains that does come up
when using CMOS technologies that this
pattern becomes visible either with
averaging or specific light levels not
exactly sure why but this process with
the back then sensor however the pixel
of designed and the the structure behind
it gives you very clean images I've
actually scaled this image much more
aggressively than I did the front
illuminated CMOS and I I don't really
see any pattern in the background what
people have always seemed to request is
CCD like image quality from a CMOS
sensor and this newer technology seems
to to deliver that now we expect a
back-illuminated CMOS camera to be more
sensitive than a front illuminated CMOS
camera how does that compare how does
the back illuminated sensor compared to
an emc city though because again
remember f CMOS sensors have been pushed
more and more into the applications of
where AM CCD cameras set but you know
that though if you look at remember that
misshapen triangle the sensitivity
hasn't always been there and that's what
that's what this camera begins to offer
or the what this sensor begins to offer
when you compare the ninety-five percent
back-illuminated CMOS sensor to the 1k
am ccd cameras that are available you'll
see very similar levels of sensitivity
using that same standardized
fluorescence slide you're able to detect
effectively the same number of bars
between both cameras
and this is using you know a
standardized florist the slides in
actual applications when comparing an
EMC CD at the 150 x magnification to the
back illuminated CMOS you're actually
getting better image quality from the
CMOS camera and if you look closely in
these images the pixel to pixel
variation that excess noise that happens
due to the multiplication process it's
actually quite visible in the the image
it with the EMC CD and you get a much
cleaner much flatter background when
using the the back illuminated CMOS and
so mathematically how does the
signal-to-noise if these images work out
the back illuminated CMOS because you
don't have the excess noise because
you're able to measure the ninety-five
percent of signal available you're able
to get a much higher signal-to-noise
ratio when compared to both available
from the illuminated CMOS products that
are out there on the market and when
compared to emc CDs as well and so this
becomes a much more viable option as you
move CMOS technology towards the more
demanding the more the applications that
require that level of sensitivity and so
the the additional advantage you get
because the pixels on the the CMOS
sensor are smaller you don't need the
150 x magnification to appropriately
sample with with an e/m ccd camera and
as we mentioned earlier there's
trade-offs with higher levels of
magnification so with the lower
magnification you're actually getting
significantly larger fields of view 2.2
times larger than the fire or the 1k emc
CD cameras almost six times larger than
the 512 emc city cameras you're getting
somewhere between six to sixty percent
more light per pixel because of this use
of lower magnification and so
you're you're truly able to maximize the
the sensitivity and take CMOS to the
levels of performance where EMC city sat
before and you're able to do this with
all the advantages that CMOS sensors
typically typically provide the large
field of view the really high frame
rates the the the noise of around an
electron extremely high dynamic range
yep cameras are typically somewhere
between nine and ten bits of actual
dynamic range even though cameras are
you know they report 16-bit data actual
experimental dynamic range they could
offers you know 10 to 12 bits and with
these sensors you're able to get almost
usable proper 16-bit dynamic range of
being able to measure you know sixty
thousand different individual levels of
flight and so if you sort of take all of
these different technologies that we ran
through today and consider where they
would fall out in terms of the different
applications because see CDs are the
workhorse they offer you know good good
sensitivity good resolution there's
still a spot for them there's still a
place for them in the market today and
it's typically for you know hide a
medium light levels with not so high
magnification because because you get
very good spatial resolution you get
very good quality images out of it and
it's great for 6l fluorescence or photo
documentation but not so good for a
dynamic events live cell imaging
time-lapse because the as I've mentioned
the framerate is where CCS didn't quite
do so well and that's where the the
scientific CMOS devices come in the the
pixel size and the levels of sensitivity
that you get from NFC must device
actually makes it very I day I ideal for
a 60 x objective you're able to
appropriately spatially sample you have
more life per pixel because you're not
magnifying as much if it's great for the
life cell
applications or light sheet microscopy
where people are typically using six CX
objectives to and trying to maximize the
spatial resolution in your images where
the back illuminated CMOS comes in is
where EMC cities used to be in the
extremely low light flux the very
demanding applications of
single-molecule fluorescence super
resolution and other applications such
as the spinning disk confocal where the
conf ocala t blocks a lot of the light
that you would otherwise have imaged or
or turf microscopy and what what
back-illuminated CMOS technology allows
you to do is maintain those same levels
of sensitivity as you would have
previously achieved with an e/m ccd
camera but do it with better spatial
resolution a larger field of view it
provides significant advantages and and
it's not like EMC CDs are now defunct
it's not that they've been completely
replaced and now our ancient technology
EMC CD cameras will always be the most
sensitive cameras out there the the
giant pixels the near-perfect of quantum
efficiency renoise if less than an
electron if if again remember if the
first problem is I can't see myself and
the back illuminated CMOS isn't quite
enough then an EMC city will always be a
viable option but for the majority of
applications for the majority of
applications where light flux is quite
low back illuminated CMOS becomes a much
more viable option there's no need to
try and shoehorn the smaller pixel front
illuminated CMOS technology into where
the e/m ccd cameras previously were were
positioned and so the reason we're
talking about the the back illuminated
CMOS is photometrics has a camera the
prime95 be and this dis camera it
effectively combines the advantages of
emc should again CMOS you get the emc
City levels of sense
d you get the dynamic range noise frame
rates of CMOS technology and your three
times more sensitive previously or than
previous or current existing CMOS
cameras and you're able to get the same
level of sensitivity as EMC CD cameras
with better signal-to-noise ratio so I
guess with that taking you through that
I'd like to thank you for attending and
if we should go through some of the
questions that have been asked thank you
arrested for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
look a question you'd like to ask
ratchet please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window type your
question into the box it appears on your
screen and click on the send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for let's get started first question is
how about deconvolution of image specs
from 95% back-illuminated where do we
get in terms of resolution and just let
me know if you need to repeat that last
I guess if you could please sure how
about deconvolution of image stacks from
95% back-illuminated where do we get in
terms of resolution um while we haven't
run the camera through ad convolutions
yet the better the data going in is
typically the better data coming out and
so I would expect deconvolution image
stacks with with the 95 be to be a very
very good very high quality you don't
have the the variation and excess noise
that you would have with the MC CDs and
you have the same level of performance
that you're you're getting with current
front illuminated sensors in terms of
noise and so which have been used for
deconvolution so i would think that your
results would be quite good can the
denoising algorithms be used on emc CDs
yes the the denoising algorithms can be
used on emc CDs one of the limiting
factors actually is the number of pixels
on a sensor so for example because we're
looking for structure and similarity in
an image the the less the spatial
information there is the the less that
you're able to reduce the noise but
there are implementations that can use
3d images of stacks to to minimize that
noise on emc CDs now you're not
necessarily removing the excess noise
from the measurements but you are
removing the you are reducing the
effects of the image are the noise in
the image this is the prime 95%
back-illuminated has enhanced function
to I would keep your ear out for that
actually at this time it does not but
being based on the prime platform of
cameras from photometrics it's
definitely something to keep an eye out
for in the future if it's a denoise
algorithm free so currently the the
denoising algorithm is available on one
of the photometrics cameras the
photometrics prime there are
publications out there that that talk
about and discuss and explain how the
algorithm works but to get access to the
algorithm you actually have to go to the
QE Institute in in France and request a
license to be able to get access to the
to the algorithm what is the pixel count
the resolution and highest profane frame
rate of the prime 95% back-illuminated
and also what is the pixel size so the
prime 95 B is a 1200 x 1200 sensor so
1.4 for megapixel and it has two game
modes there's a 16-bit 16-bit mode where
you get 41 frames per second and a high
gain 12 bit mode where you get 81 frames
per second the pixel size of the camera
is 1111 by 11
microns so 120 1 micron squared when is
the BMI CMOS camera available the camera
is available now you can go to our
website and request demos and the are
our sales reps will be in contact with
you and can come out and show you the
camera and if denoising done in a camera
or on the computer the denoising is
actually done on the camera itself from
our implementation on camera is it is
done on the camera head there's an
embedded signal processing engine that
we've placed on the camera to to give
give you this data in real time and the
reason for that is being able to get
this data in real time and not having to
go post process and take the time to
transfer all of that data it allows you
to get better results immediately you're
suggesting that we switch our en ccd out
for a BSI CMOS is it worth making a
change I think for the most part as as
you move forward the back lamented CMOS
becomes a more versatile option but it
doesn't mean that EMC csr now are now
defunct they still offer grade levels of
sensitivity and great frame rates just
as technology develops you're able to
add more functionality and better
performance as this technology
progresses and that's what the the back
illuminated CMOS represents what image
acquisition software can be used with
the prime95 be metamorph micromanager
can the denoising algorithms be turned
on or off currently for the 95 be the
camera will be supported in micromanager
we are working to support in other
software packages and yes the denoising
algorithm can be turned on or off at
your discretion can the primer 95 DB
used to quantify fluorescence
yes it's a scientific camera that
provides proper linear performance and
can be used to quantify your fluorescent
signals how does the 95 feet temperature
with the Orca flash four-point-oh in
terms of first absolute imaging area and
second maximum frame rate and third
sensitivity at low levels low light
levels you want me to separate that out
so how does the 95 feet compared with
your Flash four-point-oh first in terms
of absolute imaging area so the absolute
imaging area is effectively the same I
believe that the the 2k by two KS CMOS
sensor has a diagonal of about eighteen
point seven millimeters the prime95 be
sensor has a diagonal of 18.6 six
effectively the same so you get the same
field of view out of the sensor then how
does a 95 be compared with Orca flash
part 4 50 in terms of maximum frame rate
so full frame the Orca flesh for the the
photometrics prime or any of the front
illuminated CMOS cameras are able to
achieve a hundred frames a second as the
maximum full frame rate the prime 95 B
is able to achieve 81 82 frames per
second and then how does the 95 be
compared with or flash four-point-oh
interest and sensitivity at low light
levels um as I shown in those images uh
earlier the in the stack guy you're
getting about a three times increase in
sensitivity when you compare the front
illuminated CMOS to the back illuminated
CMOS to the prime95 be you're getting an
increased due to pixel size and you're
getting an increased due to the higher
quantum efficiency as well that
translates out to about three times
three point three times more sensitive
and lastly how does it compare in terms
of signal to noise ratio the
signal-to-noise ratio for the 95b will
be higher a because there's more signal
measured per frame and
having more signal will always preparar
you will always reduce the the noise in
your image by at least a factor of the
square root of the signal and so you'll
always get a significantly higher
signal-to-noise ratio when comparing the
two if I jump back to this slide what
you can see here is the the red curve is
the prime 95 V and the two green curves
along the bottom are the the current
front illuminated CMOS cameras the light
green being the seventy percent and the
dark green being the eighty percent
versions the most accurate way to
compare the 95 d to the prime would be
with equal effective pixel size so 2
times 2 binning with the prime under
these conditions which one has better
signal-to-noise ratio and how does it
vary with light levels and they also say
the 95b has higher qy but the prime
would benefit from thinning it small
pixel so yes by if you if you equate the
pixel size between the two you'll still
have an advantage with the prime95 be
because of the quantum efficiency and so
the difference does become closer but
the 95 VA still overall more sensitive
even though you can have the equivalent
pixel size effectively the difference in
conversion if available signal will
always be higher with the back of
ammonia did CMOS we explain how this
camera is three times more sensitive
than the current SD MOS technology was
only about twelve percent increase in
quantum efficiency and when you consider
the difference in pixel size that you
did with the SE mas versus the emc CD
comparison what is the true gain I just
jumped away from me huh what is the true
gain question the question just jumped
away from there sorry about that oh it's
okay um so what you're actually getting
is if I do the quick calculation
so yeah so you're getting about a
sixteen percent increase in sensitive
sensitivity just due to the quantum
efficiency and so when you consider the
difference in pixel size what is the
true gain insensitivity I if I remember
the math off the top of my head I think
you still end up being about twenty to
thirty percent more sensitive with the
95 be when you use a 60 x magnification
with the prime 95 be the other thing to
consider is that the image quality that
you're able to get with the 95 bees
actually much cleaner overall and that
will definitely play an effect as well
which a CMOS camera was used for
comparison uh were for the most part the
comparison was done versus the images
were were the images said which cameras
were used some of the comparisons were
done versus the eighty-two percent s
CMOS camera and some of the comparisons
were labeled Prime were done would be
seventy two percent des Tomas camera is
100 FPS possible with denoising know one
of the issues that were one of the
trade-offs when any image processing
algorithm is uses typically they tend to
be quite information intensive and so
one of the trade-offs that you do have
to make when doing denoising is that the
frame rate is reduced how did the renos
compared to that of the evolved 512 so
the readers of the evolved 512 without
iam gain is about 250 270 electrons but
with BM gain you're able to reduce that
effectively to less than one electron
proportionally and so the the prime95 be
is able to get your read noise of about
1.3 electrons so quite close while so
while am CCD cameras have the advantage
in the
raw read noise value the CMOS technology
offers readers right around the levels
of one electron if it fits to the in
vivo imaging to uh yes why not the
sensitivity out into the near-ir is
better than the current a CMOS
technology out there and is equivalent
or slightly better than the emc City
technology out there as well and I'm
going to just pause for quick second
because it looks like there's more
questions coming in and I just want to
let see I just want to see me we have
time to answer all new more question
let's see from which manufacturer did
you use the cameras for the SE mas
comparison uh while I don't want to
explicitly say which manufacturer was
used there we did use some of the
eighty-two percent s CMOS sensors and we
used our own phone metrics prime for the
seventy two percent comparison what is
the fastest spring rate possible with
the denoising on about 17 frames per
second is the fast that you can go fast
as you can go with denoising that again
it looks like more questions coming in
so we'll just pause for a moment
would you like to know if and when the
needy memorizing option will be
available on the 95 be when and if that
feature is added to the camera we will
be sure to let to let everyone know
right and again more questions so just
give me a minute here just comparisons
of images with and without denoising uh
yes so if we let me get to be slide if
we look at these images here these are
using the photometrics prime seventy-two
percent s CMOS camera on the left is the
undie no image and on the right is the D
noised image same exposure time same
scaling are you suggesting that we
switch our ends GCD out for BSI CMOS and
is it worth making the change I don't do
that one already I'm sorry ya know that
that's fine i think is it worth
switching it out no I think you're am
camera will do you just fine but as you
move forward and look at future camera
purchases I think the 95 B becomes the
more the better solution you have images
comparing the Dino HTM CCD and dino SE
mas performance ah yes so if we look at
this slide this on the left we have the
emc CD with no denoising compared to the
s CMOS camera with be noising what is
the maximum frame rate achievable for
small region of interest for instance 12
x eight I will have to get back to you
on that one specifically and how
out the longest exposure value 495 be
currently that is set to 10 seconds
typically these cameras use for much
lower light flux and exposure times
arranged into the few hundreds of
milliseconds at the most by providing a
max exposure time of 10 seconds we're
giving you I think a pretty decent range
of flexibility there if you want to
expose for longer periods of time you
actually probably should be using CCD
technology they offer much lower dark
current than CMOS technology and are
better for long stare applications and
let me know if this is trouble here are
the signal-to-noise ratio versus photon
flux curves corrected for 45 so yes
pixel size is taken into account all
right so um i would like to once again
thank ratchet mahindra for his
presentation do you have any final
comments for us today I think in general
as technology has progressed everyone
expected the the back illuminated CMOS
to to become a reality and by having a
camera that demonstrates this
significantly improved performance over
current CMOS technology I think it's
what many people have been waiting for
to to be to take the advantage of CMOS
technology and apply them to where EMCC
news had been used previously and I
think thank everyone for attending and
hopefully it was good useful information
thank you once again I would also like
to thank our sponsor photometrics for
making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 14
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be
elbow for replay we sure that
announcement with your colleagues from
you have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye